alguna vez os habéis preguntado cuál es
el país del mundo en el que más llueve y
no antes de que se anticipe esta vez que
la respuesta no tiene absolutamente nada
que ver con el título de este vídeo el
país donde más llueve de todo el planeta
no es otro que colombia pero no este
vídeo no va sobre el país del café la
bandeja paisa y el sancocho que los
amigos amigas a pesar de no ser el
número uno nuestro protagonista de hoy
singapur si está en la parte alta muy
alta de este particular ranking mundial
en concreto ocupa la decimocuarta plaza
con unos 2400 milímetros al año de
precipitaciones medias así que no sé lo
primero que podríamos pensar es que
singapur sobre el agua verdad pues no o
al menos no exactamente lo cierto es que
a pesar de ser uno de los países más
pasados por agua de todo el planeta
sufren problemas de escasez así que aquí
no surgen dos preguntas clave como
demonios es posible que sufran escasez
de agua con todo lo que llueve y que ha
hecho y qué piensa hacer singapur para
atajar este problema queridos amigos
amigas os acordáis del vídeo que hicimos
sobre israel y el milagro del agua pues
ojo porque los hijos de merlion no se
quieren quedar atrás atentos
[Aplausos]
si sois seguidores habituales de visual
politics seguro seguro que conocéis a
nuestro patrocinador de hoy vincero
collective
en esta ocasión os queremos presentar el
nuevo cargo automatic
con cuerpo y correa de acero inoxidable
y quirúrgico una resistencia al agua de
hasta 20 atmósferas y cristal de zafiro
a prueba de arañazos este reloj no
necesitará que nunca le cambien las
pilas porque sorpresa no tiene pilas y
si lo habéis escuchado bien con su
mecanismo millo está automático este
reloj se recarga con el propio
movimiento de tu cuerpo y si por
cualquier motivo os lo queréis quitar
cuenta además con una batería de
respaldo que le garantiza hasta 40 horas
de funcionamiento todo así de sencillo
es decir que ya nunca más vas a tener
que volver a pasar por esa horrible
sensación del reloj al que se le agotan
las pilas y luego nunca te acuerdas de
cambiarlas y nos a vosotros pero a mí
esto me ha ganado del todo porque me
pasa constantemente y qué queréis que os
diga a mí este color verde la verdad es
que me gusta un montón no se me parece
clásico pero también a la vez fresco y
rompedor no me digáis que no le da un
puntito de todas formas lo tenéis en
otros cuatro diferentes y os
preguntaréis pero es realmente
resistente qué ocurre si lo pido me
llega ahí luego no me convence pues
atentos porque a mí esto me encanta muy
muy importante me quiero están tan
convencidos de la calidad de sus relojes
que te ofrecen cinco años de garantía ni
un periodo de devolución de
365 días sí si lo habéis escuchado bien
os lo vais a poder pensar durante todo
un año y si luego no os convence pues lo
podéis devolver o cambiarlo por otro eso
sí siempre y cuando el reloj esté
intacto claro pero un momento porque
ahora viene lo mejor de todo por ser
miembros de la comunidad visual polític
vais a poder haceros con el nuevo algo
con un 15 por ciento de descuento y
envío gratuito tan sólo tendréis que
utilizar el código político en vincero
collective puntocom barra política así
de fácil y ahora si arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
como diríamos en megaproyectos singapur
es un país fascinante un lugar del que
por cierto nos encanta hablar aquí en
visual político ahora bien aunque
normalmente nos ocupamos de cuestiones
como la seguridad jurídica el modelo
económico o incluso la defensa militar
esta vez vamos a echar un vistazo a un
tema radicalmente diferente el agua lo
sé lo sé de seguro que en este preciso
momento muchos os preguntáis pero a ver
enrique qué demonios tiene que ver el
agua con la política que no sé al fin y
al cabo es de lo que se supone que trata
este canal pues sabéis que lo cierto es
que tienen mucha pero que mucha relación
mucho más de la que podrías imaginar a
simple vista
[Música]
a pesar de que singapur es uno de los
países donde más llueve de todo el mundo
el problema es que también es uno de los
más densamente poblados con unos 5
millones y medio de habitantes en una
superficie de poco más de 700 kilómetros
cuadrados no hay suficiente espacio para
almacenar el agua dulce que cae en forma
de lluvia claro os imagináis por ejemplo
un gran embalse en plena ciudad seguro
ganó en total esta ciudad-estado tiene
17 embalses de captación de agua pero
lógicamente la mayoría son muy pequeños
y no son capaces de satisfacer la enorme
demanda de agua que tiene esta ciudad es
precisamente por este motivo por el que
la gestión del agua se ha convertido en
una cuestión clave en la política del
país
[Música]
de hecho singapur es considerado uno de
los países con más estrés hídrico del
mundo y ocupa la primera posición entre
los 33 países en riesgo extremo de
estrés hídrico para el 2040 claro
gracias a su prosperidad económica a la
ciudad no para de crecer y con ella
también la demanda de agua fijaos
[Música]
claro que no se trata solo de la
población a pesar de ser un país
eminentemente urbano más del 55 por
ciento de toda la demanda de agua
procede de la actividad económica no de
los hogares un porcentaje que además
espera se incrementa hasta el 70% para
el año 2060 ya os he dicho que singapur
no deja de crecer industria turismo e
incluso experimentos agrícolas de los
que por cierto ya os hablamos en un
vídeo pasado aquí el visual político así
que con todo esto en mente la pregunta
es cómo diantres se puede garantizar el
suministro de agua en un país con un
territorio cada vez más presionado por
la creciente acumulación de viviendas
industrias hoteles y comercios de todo
tipo qué planes se guardan bajo la manga
en uno de los territorios más ricos y
prósperos del planeta pues bien veámoslo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el agua también es política
ya os lo hemos dicho la ciudad del león'
con cuerpo de pez es uno de los lugares
más urbanizados densamente poblados y
más dependientes del mundo en lo que
respecta al agua y claro la capacidad
para construir infraestructuras es a
priori limitada y es una cuestión
básicamente de metros cuadrados por eso
aproximadamente la mitad de todo el agua
que se consume en el país es importada
de su vecino más próximo malasia y
sabéis que justo aquí es donde se
produce todo el jaleo el politiqueo puro
y duro' en toda esta cuestión porque
queridos amigos amigas el suministro de
agua en esta ciudad de estado hoy por
hoy depende fundamentalmente de un
acuerdo muy antiguo y muy bien negociado
por parte de singapur un acuerdo con las
autoridades del estado de johor que no
gustan nada pero que nada de nada al
gobierno malasio
no
y gracias al acuerdo con el estado de
johor singapur opera una presa que le
permite importar actualmente cerca de
900 millones de litros diarios de agua
sin tratar desde el país vecino el
problema para los malasios es su precio
las autoridades singapurenses y las del
estado de johor acordaron una
compensación por el agua extraída de 3
sen malasios por cada 1000 galones lo
que equivale a unos 000 siete dólares
americanos por cada tres mil 785 litros
de agua el motivo de que el precio sea
tan irrisorio es que no puede ser
modificado unilateralmente el acuerdo
que entró en vigor en 1962 y es válido
por 99 años establece que ese precio no
podría modificarse transcurridos los
primeros 25 años es decir que el precio
desde 1987 es invariable
y eso no es todo el acuerdo incluye
también una cláusula que le obliga a
singapur a revender de nueva york hasta
el 2 por ciento del agua que importa
después de ser tratada y potabilizada a
un precio eso sí de 50 por cada 1000
galones es decir para que nos entendamos
singapur importa 1000 galones de agua
sin tratar a 3 cm y luego vende 1000
galones de agua tratadas a 50 cent con
este ajuste prácticamente se pagan un
porcentaje muy importante de todo el
agua consumida además para colmo el
acuerdo tampoco estableció ningún tipo
de revisión del precio en base a la
inflación ni nada por el estilo no sé un
buen acuerdo para singapur no os parece
singapur claro y consistente en la
posición de que malasia ha perdido su
derecho a revisar el precio del agua
bajo el acuerdo de 1962 así que tal y
como os podéis imaginar todo esto es
algo que ha generado una enorme
frustración para malasia
normal el acuerdo implica la práctica
regalarle el agua singapur así que se
han producido un montón de tiras y
aflojas y conflictos diplomáticos entre
los dos países precisamente a cuenta del
agua y claro eso es lo que explica en
noticias como esta a javi revive la
disputa del agua con singapur califica
el acuerdo de 1962 de ridículo pero
ahora bien un momento el acuerdo no es
para siempre
tal y como os hemos dicho tiene una
duración de 99 años lo que significa que
en 2.061 singapur perderá su derecho a
importar agua en condiciones tan
ventajosas además tal y como ya os
contamos en un pasado vídeo aquí en
visual político singapur es una especie
de fortín así que tampoco quieren tener
tanta dependencia de un tercer país para
algo tan importante lo consideraban algo
así como una debilidad estratégica casi
casi un problema de seguridad nacional y
si vale lo sé para que llegue el año
2060 y uno aún queda mucho tiempo pero
sabéis que en singapur ya se están
preparando os lo hemos dicho en un
montón de vídeos a esta gente les gusta
ser precavido así que dicho y hecho el
gobierno de singapur se ha marcado como
un objetivo fundamental lograr como muy
tarde para el año 2060 la
autosuficiencia hídrica un gigantesco
reto para el cual la ciudad-estado ha
puesto en marcha un plan que combina la
reducción del consumo el aprovechamiento
de hasta la última gota y por supuesto
la capacidad de producir agua limpia por
sí mismos conseguir un suministro
abundante económico y potencialmente
ilimitado de agua dulce pero queréis
saber cómo esperan conseguirlo
atentos
[Música]
los cuatro grifos de singapur
amigos tal y como os comentamos al
principio del vídeo a pesar de que en
singapur las lluvias son muy abundantes
el problema está en que no tienen aguas
subterráneas aprovechables ni tampoco
grandes cuerpos de agua dulce
disponibles es de cajón que no hay sitio
para grandes embalses pues bien
actualmente y para solventar este
inconveniente la gestión actual del agua
se basa en lo que se ha bautizado como
los cuatro grifos nacionales esto es las
cuatro grandes fuentes de agua del país
la primera de ellas es precisamente la
que se basa en la captación de agua de
las cuencas locales para alimentar una
red de micro embalses y depósitos
[Música]
para potenciar esta fuente de agua ya en
1972 singapur impulsó el conocido como
plan maestro del agua un plan que
consistió en identificar todas las áreas
posibles de captación y embalses para
recolectar el agua de la lluvia y
utilizarla en el sistema de suministro
gracias a este plan se crearon nuevos
embalses hasta alcanzar la cifra de 17
con los que cuenta actualmente entre
ellos un gran embalse urbano que baña el
corazón de esta ciudad-estado incluyendo
su lugar más famoso marina bay
si lo habéis escuchado bien aunque nos
pueda sorprender desde el año 2008 esa
inmensa laguna a la histórica bahía
característica de singapur el lugar
donde el merlín vierte sus aguas se ha
convertido en todo un embalse de agua
dulce luego del segundo grifo nacional
ya os hemos hablado es el agua importada
desde malasia una fuente que
previsiblemente tiene fecha de caducidad
el año 2000 61 y por último en tercer y
cuarto lugar están respectivamente el
new water y el agua desalinizada y ojo
porque estos dos grifos nacionales son
de lo más interesante y la clave para
alcanzar la autosuficiencia hídrica en
especial el cni water
[Música]
new water es uno de los sistemas de agua
recuperada o reciclada más avanzados del
mundo y la apuesta principal de singapur
para lograr la autosuficiencia hídrica
consiste en un sistema de filtrado de
cuatro barreras que convierte a agua
residual es decir el agua ya utilizada
en agua potable primero el agua pasa por
un tratamiento de depuración
convencional después pasa por una
segunda fase consistente en sistemas de
micro y ultra filtración a través de
membranas extremadamente finas la
tercera etapa consiste en la ósmosis
inversa un sistema de depuración a
presión que elimina moléculas indeseadas
iones grandes partículas y sales y
minerales que no quieres que estén ahí y
por último como cuarta barrera se le
aplica rayos ultravioleta y desinfectan
de bacterias el agua
parece un sistema complejo pero en
realidad no lo es tanto singapur cuenta
con cinco plantas new water que se
dedican a recuperar aguas residuales y
una sexta entrará en funcionamiento en
el año 2025 y vale seguro seguro que os
estáis preguntando pero este agua se
bebe pues y la respuesta es que si ese
agua perfectamente aprovechable para el
consumo humano de hecho el proceso de
new water ha superado más de 150.000
pruebas científicas que le han hecho
conseguir el aprobado de la organización
mundial de la salud y su calificación
como agua potable segura ultra limpia
[Música]
a pesar de ello y supongo que por una
cuestión de recelos no me digáis que
vosotros no lo tendríais el agua de ni
water se suministra por lo general de
forma separada principalmente para usos
industriales y comerciales o por ejemplo
para sistemas de enfriamiento de aires
acondicionados de tamaño industrial
porque si en singapur el aire
acondicionado lo que queréis que os diga
es un aparato fundamental pero ojo un
momento porque esto poco a poco está
cambiando una parte de este agua si se
utiliza ya para complementar el
suministro de agua potable doméstica
como pues se bombea una parte de ella y
se mezcla con el agua de los embalses
destinados al consumo doméstico y claro
teniendo en cuenta las limitaciones que
existen el agua bombeada por new water
para consumo doméstico va cobrando cada
vez más y más importancia y de hecho se
espera que para el año 2060 suponga más
de la mitad de todo el consumo de agua
amigos amigas ni siquiera israel ha
llegado y proyectan lejos y luego por
último tendríamos el agua desalinizada
esta cuarta fuente nacional no es tan
novedosa desde hace mucho tiempo la
podemos encontrar casi por todas partes
[Música]
actualmente singapore cuenta con 4
desalinizadoras que son capaces de
satisfacer un elevado porcentaje de la
demanda de agua tanto es así que la idea
es que para 2060 el agua desalinizada
surta hasta el 30 por ciento de la
demanda nacional lo que sumado al agua
procedente del new water se espera que
garantice hasta el 85 por ciento del
consumo de agua nacional diciendo además
contar con importantes reservas de agua
dulce en la red de almacenamiento
principal
no os parece algo realmente increíble
desde luego si tenemos en cuenta tanto
el caso de israel como el de singapur
parece que cuando se habla de escasez de
agua no se quiere decir sobre todo mala
gestión del agua
[Música]
el caso es que con este plan es como
singapur es para lograr la
autosuficiencia para el año 2000 61
cuando expire el contrato de importación
de agua de malasia en ese momento se
espera que los cuatro grifos nacionales
se conviertan en tres y si obviamente
este plan conlleva un esfuerzo titánico
importantes inversiones que por supuesto
no son gratis
singapur subirá el precio del agua un 30
por ciento en dos años claro que por
otra parte singapore puede llegar a
convertirse en un futuro próximo en un
importante exportador de tecnologías de
gestión aprovechamiento y tratamiento de
agua no sé pensadlo que estas técnicas
supondrían en países como arabia saudita
qatar emiratos árabes o incluso en un
sitio con una gestión de aguas tan
desastrosa como la india y que queréis
que os diga si alguien sabe hacer dinero
esos son precisamente las gentes de
singapur no os parece eso si dinero a
cambio de prosperidad y agua dulce para
todos pero amigos llegados hasta aquí
turno para ti crees que los avances
tecnológicos permitirán solucionar en el
futuro los problemas de agua en el mundo
y con ellas los posibles retos políticos
que puedan surgir supondrá la tecnología
de singapur el fin de la escasez de agua
déjanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios y
si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis de like y
suscribiros abisal político muy
importante si te gusta lo que hacemos y
quieres más te invitamos a sumarte a
nuestra comunidad de patrick además de
contribuir a que sigamos creando
contenido independiente podrás recibir
las claves de la semana a lata político
productos exclusivos y entre otras
muchas cosas os dejamos el enlace por
aquí abajo en la descripción una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]